>> SALLY: Hallo! Herzlich
>> MURAT: Hi!
>> SALLY: willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Jetzt denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich:
"Was machen die zwei hier in der Küche?"
Es wird kein langweiliges Video, denn...
>> MURAT: Was haben sie vor?
>> SALLY: Was haben sie vor?
Ja.
Wir stehen hier nicht in Waghäusel in unserer Küche.
Nein, wir sind im Q 6 Q 7, im Einkaufszentrum in Mannheim,
und sind im ersten Obergeschoss in unserem Store,
unser Sallys Store.
Ja, herzlich willkommen!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir haben seit
– heute den dritten Tag geöffnet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und man muss sagen,
der Sallys Store, den haben wir uns
schon seit über einem Jahr – nicht? –
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: planen wir dran und machen und tun
und organisieren. Und
es war alles etwas anders geplant,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: als es jetzt ist.
Es kam natürlich viel dazwischen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir wollen euch heute mitnehmen
in die kleine Zeitreise zurück an den Anfang,
als wir noch gedacht haben:
"Mensch, wir machen hier den Store auf,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: machen eine fette Küche rein
>> MURAT: Als wir noch dachten, es wäre eine gute Idee.
>> SALLY: wie zu Hause."
Und dann kam leider alles anders als geplant.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da war es wohl nichts mit der Eröffnung.
>> SALLY: Und ich stehe jetzt zwar hier
und sage das hier so fröhlich, aber im...
Also eigentlich macht es mich ziemlich traurig,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: weil wir wirklich alles superschön
organisiert und vorbereitet hatten
und jetzt sozusagen vieles ausfällt.
Aber dennoch wollen wir euch zeigen,
wie dieser Shop entstanden ist.
Ich will mich, glaube ich, jetzt schon mal kurz entschuldigen
dafür, dass wir die Eröffnung nicht angekündigt haben.
Aber es hat einfach viele Gründe.
Wir dürfen zum einen keine Menschenmassen hier anziehen.
Wir müssen einfach Sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir müssen leider alle Masken tragen.
>> MURAT: In die Mall dürfen nur 900 Leute rein insgesamt.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und...
>> MURAT: Und wenn wir eine Eröffnung machen
und es kommen drei- bis viertausend Leute,
dann haben die anderen Händler hier drin nichts mehr davon.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: Das wäre unfair. Das ist unsolidarisch.
Und gerade zur heutigen Zeit sollte man Solidarität zeigen.
Es gibt keine Konkurrenz, nur ein Wirgefühl.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und deswegen haben wir das
klein und heimlich gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Natürlich möchte ich euch trotzdem gerne zeigen,
wie alles angefangen hat.
Und deswegen gehen wir jetzt ganz an den Anfang zurück.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Wenn ihr hier Q6 seht, dann seid ihr richtig.
Da gehen wir jetzt rein.
>> MURAT: Genau.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ja, und hier hinter uns seht ihr den Shop.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist er gerade noch zu, denn wir bauen ja noch.
>> MURAT: Genau, der hat gerade zu.
Der hat 14 Meter und zwar die Fensterfläche, Laufmeter.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wird komplett aufgemacht, wird riesengroß.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Heute war hier Pressekonferenz.
Das heißt, heute haben wir eröffnet,
dass es hier einen Sally-Shop geben wird.
Und jetzt zeige ich euch mal,
wie der Laden momentan noch aussieht.
Ich war vor Kurzem schon da.
Da waren noch die Überreste vom Laden zuvor drin.
Und heute sind Güni und Alex schon da seit ein paar Tagen
und werkeln schon.
Kommt mal mit. Ich zeige euch das mal.
Ja, so sieht es hier momentan gerade aus.
Also man kann sich ein bisschen schon was vorstellen.
Hier vorne gibt es dann die Kasse,
da rechts und links die Regale.
Die ganze Fensterfront wird zugemacht.
Da machen wir dann so LED-Panels nach außen.
Dann können wir nämlich nach außen
auch die Videos ausstrahlen.
Und das sieht man dann außen von der Fressgass'.
Also, wenn man dann wirklich nach oben schaut,
dann sieht man bei uns kein Schaufenster,
sondern eben einen Bildschirm.
Und da lassen wir dann eben alles laufen,
worauf wir gerade Lust haben.
Und hinter mir kommt die Küche hin
und das wird die Küche eins zu eins wie bei mir daheim.
Ja, ich glaube, das wird ziemlich cool.
Aber ich kann mir momentan
– das ist, glaube ich, wie in so einer Wohnung,
die man so frisch bezieht,
so bei einer Wohnungsbesichtigung –
noch nicht vorstellen, wie groß das alles wird.
Also ja,
ich bin mal gespannt.
Aber ich glaube, es wird schön.
Ja.
Jetzt wird gebaut.
Piu!
[Musik]
Unser Shop, so langsam wird er.
Ja.
Wir haben jetzt voll viel schon eingeräumt.
Also wir haben die ganze Kochblume-Ware,
die ganze GEFU-Ware, die ganze Sally-Ware,
KitchenAid, Kenwood.
Was habe ich noch?
Dekoback.
Haben wir alles schon verräumt.
Was wir jetzt gerade noch machen
– also das Lager ist schon voll,
die Regale an der Wand sind schon voll.
Was wir jetzt hier machen:
Ich habe mir vorgestellt,
dass wir immer so Thementische haben.
Und jetzt fangen wir an mit dem ersten Thementisch.
Das ist der Thementisch Rosa!
Das heißt, alles, was rosa ist, kommt hier auf einen Tisch.
Dann machen wir einen Carbon-Black-Tisch.
Dann machen wir einen Torten-Fondant-Modellier-Tisch.
Ja, lauter Thementische,
dass man einfach so die Vielfalt sieht,
was passt zueinander.
Und wir schaffen so kleine Welten
in Sallys Welt.
Okay.
Also Gusseisenteekanne.
Schön, oder?
>> AYLIN: Ja!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ja, und das ist der Kassenbereich.
Und, wie es halt gerade überall ist,
aufgrund der Verordnungen
müssen wir so einen Spuckschutz machen.
Und zwar ist das wie so eine Schutzwand,
dass, wenn man spricht,
man keine Tröpfcheninfektion bekommt.
Das, der Spuckschutz, hat der Güni aber schon seit Jahren.
Der trägt das seit Jahren schon.
Güni, oder?
Güni?
Du musst ja auch immer so einen Spuckschutz tragen, gell?
Aber schon seit längerer Zeit.
Das war bei dem schon immer Gesetz.
>> GÜNI: Schon klar.
>> MURAT: Güni, muss man hier übrigens auch noch ein Ding,
so ein Dach drüber machen?
>> GÜNI: Ja, für dich.
>> MURAT: Ja?
Genau. Also ein Dach müssen wir auch noch machen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das nachher aussieht.
[Musik]
So.
Hier drin haben wir was ganz, ganz Besonderes.
Und zwar ist es ein Giant Stand Mixer.
Und dieses
Ding, was hier drin ist,
das gibt es normalerweise nur auf ganz internationalen,
ganz großen Messen.
Und das ist jetzt in Mannheim das allererste Mal.
Und der wird auch in Mannheim stehen bleiben.
Daniel und ich werden das Ding jetzt auspacken.
Und schaut euch dieses Riesending mal an!
Packen wir es mal aus, Daniel?
>> DANIEL: Ja, gerne.
>> MURAT: Bist du gespannt, was drin ist?
>> DANIEL: Absolut.
>> MURAT: Okay, los!
[Musik]
Das
wird wahrscheinlich der größte Bienenstich,
den ich jemals in meinem Leben gebacken habe.
Wahnsinn!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Shop in Mannheim!
Ich habe mich wie Alice im Wunderland klein gezaubert
und bin jetzt in der Küchenmaschine.
Da gefällt es mir gut.
Da gehe ich wieder rein.
Hello!
Heute geht es weiter
bei uns hier im Shop.
So.
Jetzt bin ich endlich daheim!
Los geht's!
[Musik]
Ja, was wir jetzt gerade machen, ist,
20.000 Artikel zu etikettieren.
Und zwar haben wir dann nämlich unseren Bestand,
wissen, was da ist,
und dann wird alles noch mal fertiggestellt.
Dauert jetzt schon eine Weile.
Also wir sind schon seit ein paar Tagen dran
und es dauert, glaube ich, noch ein paar Tage.
>> SAMIRA: Mama, ich helfe dir.
>> SALLY: Du hilfst mir, Schatz. Dann sind wir schneller.
[Musik]
Ta-da-da-daa!
Also erst mal
– klar, erst mal alles gewaschen.
Das nimmt ja schon viel Zeit in Anspruch.
Alles gewaschen und abgetrocknet.
Und hier kann ich dann meinen Vorrat reinmachen.
Wenn ich hier dann koche und backe,
habe ich immer was da,
Mehl und so weiter.
Aber wir müssen noch einkaufen.
Ja, aber ich habe zumindest schon mal
so den Platz blockiert und reserviert
und habe jetzt gedacht, hier passen ja ganz gut
– weil das ist ja so ein toller Organisationsschrank.
Da hat man hier praktisch so ein Drittel des Schrankinhalts
und hier so die restlichen zwei Drittel.
Und da, habe ich gedacht, machen wir die,
die Mepal-Dosen hier rein
und hier noch meine Vorratsdosen
und dann noch die Vorräte.
Ja.
Das sieht gut aus.
Und ansonsten habe ich mir überlegt,
dass wir jetzt die Küche
noch mit den Pastellfarben einrichten.
Weil mir ist gerade so nach Pastell.
Und so im August, September
können wir dann wieder Senfgelb machen.
Ja, ich habe hier auch schon angefangen einzurichten.
Also auch hier in den Schubladen
– ta-da-daa! –
geht es schon ganz gut.
Ich habe so ein bisschen sortiert.
Josh, hier sind auch die Fernbedienungen
für die Küche.
Achtung.
Ta-daa!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Ich dekoriere jetzt gerade hier
die Messerbox.
Und zwar kommt da ein Glas drüber,
dass man nicht in die Messer reingreifen kann.
Die sind saumäßig scharf!
Mit dem Josh zusammen haben wir
hier wirklich coole Sachen gemacht,
eingelasert und Bretter zusammengesägt und geschliffen.
Und das sieht richtig cool aus!
Perfekt!
Perfekt! Hier kann nichts passieren.
So. Jetzt brauche ich noch jemand Starkes,
der mir das Glas hier hochhebt.
Genau,
Sally.
Ja, und...
Schaffst du das, Schatz?
>> SALLY: Ha ja.
Schaffst du es?
>> MURAT: Ja, ja.
So.
Perfekt!
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Das ist
>> MURAT: Cool, oder?
>> SALLY: so schön!
>> MURAT: Die Scheibe noch sauber machen.
Sieht aber richtig cool aus, oder?
>> SALLY: Voll schön!
>> MURAT: Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: Also wer da jetzt keine Lust hat auf Schneiden,
weiß ich auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
Guck mal. Also ich finde, das ist falsch.
>> SALLY: Warum?
>> MURAT: Ganz einfach:
Wenn das Regal so
so vor dir steht, dann
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: heißt das für mich,
wenn du in einen Laden reinkommst: "Stopp."
Das ist für mich wie eine Mauer.
>> SALLY: Nein, ist es nicht, weil es ist doch...
>> MURAT: Und wenn du das länglich hast,
dann zeigt es eine Flucht nach vorne.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Das ist Psychologie!
>> SALLY: Ich suche auch oft einen Fluchtweg vor dir.
Ich würde es so machen
und die anderen verteilen einfach.
Dass es halt nicht so ein System ergibt,
sondern schön verteilen.
Ganz einfach schön grün, die Decke grün,
alles grün.
Das erhellt meine Stimmung, wenn ich hier reinkomme.
>> MURAT: Weißt du...
Weißt du, was ich mich jetzt frage?
Also ohne Witz.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Du bist immer anderer Meinung als ich.
>> SALLY: Nee, du bist immer
>> MURAT: Doch, immer!
>> SALLY: anderer Meinung!
>> MURAT: Ich frage mich manchmal,
warum du mich geheiratet hast.
>> GÜNI: Oh, Halt! Halt!
Das frage ich mich auch!
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> GÜNI: Ich habe schon alle Szenarien durchgespielt.
Ich komme nicht drauf.
Warum hast du den genommen?
Warum den?!
Warum den?
>> MURAT: Jetzt reicht es, oder?
Ist das dein Ernst?
Du bist so ein...
Du fällst mir in den Rücken, hä?
Fallen mir alle in den Rücken?
Wisst ihr was?
Dann macht es, wie ihr wollt.
Ich gehe in die Küche.
>> SALLY: Hm.
[Musik]
Das bin ich, wie ich gerade Geschirr spüle.
Ich finde, auf dem Bild
gucke ich wie Ela.
Kann das sein? So ein bisschen frech, so...
So stolz darauf, spülen zu dürfen.
Und guck mal! Ich habe auch immer so Armkettchen getragen.
Och Gott!
[Musik]
Ja, und jetzt hängen wir halt hier noch alles auf.
Alex und Güni, die machen hier gerade
die tollen Bilderrahmen.
Sarah und Selma kleben die Bilder drauf.
Da haben wir leider
– der Murat hat die falsch bestellt.
Der hat sie mit Glas bestellt.
Das muss ich jetzt sagen.
Und die reflektieren. Also dürfen wir alle wieder runterhängen
und ohne Bilderglas da aufhängen.
Ja.
Aber ihr macht das toll!
Hach, ja.
Da haben wir noch unser Willkommensschild.
Das kommt dann direkt an den Eingang.
Und ein Danke-für-deinen-Besuch-Schild,
wenn man den Laden verlässt.
Ja.
Ich meine, hier kommen ja mit Sicherheit
auch Menschen vorbei, die uns nicht kennen.
Und wenn da halt nur so ein Sallys-Logo draußen ist,
dann weiß man vielleicht nicht, was das hier sein soll.
Und deswegen, haben wir gedacht,
machen wir so ein Begrüßungsschild.
Und ich glaube, so mit dem Ausrollstab und Mehl
sieht man gleich: "Mensch, die Frau, die backt.
Die backt und sie kocht."
Ja.
Herzlich willkommen!
Ich finde es voll cool!
>> SARAH: Ganz oben drauf.
Genau so wie...
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Kann ich hier schon einkaufen?
>> SARAH: Nein, wir haben noch geschlossen.
>> SALLY: Okay. Ich komme trotzdem.
Das ist, glaube ich, jetzt der Traum von allen.
Ich gehe jetzt einfach im Laden shoppen
für meine Küche.
Ja, Ausrollstab.
Oh, großer Ausrollstab.
Hier.
Dann
große Matte.
Mh. Was brauche ich noch?
Oh, Eisportionierer.
Großeinkauf.
Jetzt noch Küchenhelfer.
Ein Flaschenöffner.
Murat sagte, so was wäre unnötig,
aber ganz ehrlich, einen Flaschenöffner braucht man.
Transforma habe ich schon.
Reiben, Knoblauchpresse
habe ich.
Küchenmaschine
Und einen Dosenöffner. Komm.
Ganz ehrlich, hier kann man seinen ganzen Hausstand füllen.
Aber ich finde es wichtig.
Weil alle Dinge, die man in der Küche haben sollte,
findet ihr auch hier.
Nichts Halbes.
Fleischklopfer, Teigschaber.
Ja.
Okay. Und dann noch
die breite Palette.
Gut.
Ich traue mich nicht.
>> JOSH: Wie? Was?
>> SALLY: Ich stand halt noch nie auf meiner Küchenbühne
und habe noch nie hier gesungen.
Ich habe Lampenfieber.
Ich kann nicht so.
I'll tell you what I want, what I really, really want!
>> SARAH: So tell me what you want!
>> SALLY: Vielleicht später, okay?
Okay. Ela, bereit?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Festhalten!
Düüt!
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt!
>> ELA: Mama, ich habe gedacht immer,
das sind,
das ist ein Ziegenfutter.
>> SALLY: Das ist Ziegenfutter?
[Musik]
Komm, Ela, steh auf.
>> ELA: Zuerst will ich es anmalen.
>> SALLY: Ela, çak!
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ah!
Noch mal!
Super!
Und jetzt könnt ihr es anmalen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Ursprünglich wollten wir
die Teppiche eigentlich überall an die Wand hinmachen,
aber wir haben keine Wandflächen mehr.
Und deswegen machen wir alle Teppiche auf den Boden.
Und man kann sie auch hier holen, die Teppiche.
Man kann sie live anschauen.
Ich habe ja schon mal ein cooles Video darüber gemacht.
Schaut mal hier:
Murat und Teppiche auf meiner Tour durch die Türkei.
Und jetzt tu ich einfach alles ausrollen.
So.
Richtig cool!
Und die Tische drüber.
Und das sieht richtig genial aus!
Kann mir jemand helfen beim Tischdrüberschieben?
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Ja!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Mein Auge geht nicht mehr auf.
Mein Auge!
>> JOSH: Ja, hallo? Ich filme hier gerade.
>> AYLIN: Wir drehen gerade ein paar Bilder.
>> SALLY: Okay, die eine fotografiert,
der andere kärchert.
Egal!
Egal.
>> SARAH: Egal!
>> SALLY: Es ist etwa 22:30 Uhr.
Wir sind leider noch nicht fertig.
Wir haben gesagt, etikettieren tun wir morgen weiter.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach
– danke!
Wir gucken jetzt einfach,
dass der Verkaufsraum hier schön wird,
dass alles einen Preis hat.
Und ich trockne Geschirr ab.
Läuft bei mir.
Und das riecht immer noch nach Linsensuppe.
>> MURAT: Sally ist Boss hier.
Deswegen kommt es jetzt in die Spülmaschine.
>> MURAT: Ich wollte vorhin nur sagen: Sally ist Boss.
>> SALLY: Sally ist Boss.
Ha ja.
Der Boss etikettiert. So.
[Musik]
Der Gerät wird nie müde.
Der Gerät schläft nie ein.
Der Gerät ist vor dem Chef im Geschäft.
Und der Gerät arbeitet schweißfrei.
Und der Gerät ist
– hat Bild falsch rum aufgeklebt.
Der Gerät tauscht.
[Musik]
Die letzten drei, vier Tage...
Wir haben hier etikettiert,
zigtausende Artikel.
Wir haben
– ich habe das Lager gemacht
mit der Aylin und mit dem Volkan,
komplett, also alles Lager.
Wir haben die Tische dekoriert mit Selma und Jessi.
Yasmin und Julia haben Ware eingeräumt, etikettiert.
Meine Cousine Nazan war noch da.
Josh hat mitgeholfen,
Sarah, Samira, Aylin,
Murat, der Rami kam,
Dennis, Bahti.
O mein Gott, ich hoffe, ich habe keinen vergessen!
Vol-
Bah-
Josh, habe ich jemanden vergessen?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß es auch nicht.
>> SALLY: Jedenfalls allen
ganz viel danke!
Alex, Güni! O mein Gott!
Alex und Güni haben hier von Anfang an
ganz alleine gearbeitet,
weil wir einfach viel zu tun hatten.
Und jetzt guckt es euch an.
Es ist vollendet!
Josh hat hier noch die Technik aufgebaut.
Siamak hat bis spätabends die ganzen Banner gemacht.
Der Daniel hat alles foliert.
Und ich denke mir gerade so:
"O mein Gott! Wir haben wir das alles geschafft?"
Irgendwie ist hier so eine Wohnung entstanden,
so eine Wohnung, die aussieht wie unser Haus.
Und alle
– unser ganzer Shop ist hier, die ganze Ware ist hier.
Und wir haben es geschafft!
Morgen ist Samstag.
Morgen werden wir eröffnen, morgen früh.
Das heißt, wir machen morgen früh noch sauber.
Es wird gesaugt. Es wird geputzt.
Wir werden die Kasse lernen.
Wir werden alles lernen.
Und dann machen wir einfach den Laden auf.
Aber jetzt, wisst ihr was?
Ich kann nicht mehr. Ich gehe ins Bett.
Oder ich schlafe einfach hier.
Oder ich gehe ins Bett.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, ich gehe ins Bett.
Denn ich bin kaputt.
Tschüss!
[Musik]
So. Jetzt ist es so weit.
Der Shop ist eröffnet.
Und momentan natürlich ziemlich blöd,
überall Maskenpflicht.
Aber es ist leider so.
Klar, der Schutz geht vor
und die Gesetze und Vorschriften natürlich auch.
Ich nehme die Maske jetzt ab, weil ich moderiere,
weil ich jetzt keine Menschen treffe
und weil Josh und ich
sozusagen sowieso in einem Team sind.
Josh trägt aber eine Maske, nur zur Info.
Ich glaube, ich muss das dazusagen,
weil sonst wieder geschimpft wird.
Ich gebe euch jetzt am besten
einfach kurz eine Shoptour
für alle, die vielleicht nicht kommen können
oder einfach sich überlegt haben,
später mal irgendwann vorbeizuschauen,
oder eben die eben gar nicht herkommen können.
Ich zeige euch kurz den Shop,
zeige euch, wie wir alles eingerichtet haben.
Und ich denke wir fangen direkt
da vorne an am Eingang.
Ja, hier ist so unser Eingangsbereich.
Natürlich die riesengroße KitchenAid.
Ich glaube, da kommen sowieso ganz viele
und bestaunen die.
Und im Prinzip habt ihr hier dann rechts
gleich so unsere KitchenAid-Ecke.
Da sieht man die ganzen schönen Farben.
Und hier kann man dann alles vor Ort bestellen
und dann wird es ganz gemütlich nach Hause geliefert.
Wir haben halt auch kein Lager hier.
Deswegen können wir eben fast gar nichts lagern
und haben hier alles auf der Verkaufsfläche.
Und dann habe ich Thementische gemacht.
Und die zeige ich euch mal, okay?
Also hier am Anfang haben wir natürlich
einen schönen rosa Tisch,
alles, was das Rosaherz begehrt.
Weiter hinten habe ich
zum Beispiel noch einen schwarzen Tisch
oder einen Gusseisentisch.
Ich habe auch einen Pastelltisch,
wo einfach das ganze Pastellsortiment drauf ist.
Hier im vorderen Bereich gibt es auch noch
einen Backtisch,
also alles, was man zum Backprozess braucht,
wie ein Backblech, Backringe, Backrahmen,
ein paar Tortenringpaletten
oder eben auch andere Backformen wie Tarteformen.
Weiter hinten habe ich dann sozusagen den Dekobereich
mit Ausrollstab, Ausrollmatte,
mit den ganzen Dekoelementen,
Spritzbeuteln zum Beispiel eben auch.
Und eins hintendran ist dann
sozusagen die Lebensmittelecke.
Da gibt es alle Tortenzubehörteile
wie zum Beispiel Lebensmittelfarben.
Ich habe Backtrennspray, Vanilleextrakt,
die verschiedenen Aromen,
aber auch Fondant und Lebensmittelfarbe.
An der Wand haben wir
sozusagen die komplette Bandbreite an Backartikeln.
Und weiter hinten geht es dann schon zum Bereich Kochen,
wo es eben Kochwerkzeug gibt aus Silikon
oder eben auch Töpfe und Pfannen.
Auf der linken Seite haben wir dann, wie gesagt, Gusseisen,
Emaille und das ist sozusagen der Bereich Kochen.
Und da sind auch die Kochbücher.
Rechts sind eher so die Backbücher.
Und hier haben wir dann noch
einen zweiten für Küchenmaschinen
und zwar die Kenwood-Station.
Und wir haben uns da dabei gedacht,
dass wir so eine Art
Vergleich auch machen.
Das heißt, ihr könnt hier auch Küchenmaschinen vergleichen,
seht eben auch, was gute Qualität bedeutet.
Und hier wird man natürlich auch super beraten.
Das haben wir natürlich auch wieder
in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Daniel gemacht.
Ramershoven kennt ihr wahrscheinlich,
ramershoven.com.
Daniel begleitet uns ja auch schon seit,
ich glaube, fünf, sechs Jahren
mit auf Messen.
Und jetzt haben wir gesagt:
"Mensch, das müssen wir natürlich auch hier anbieten",
und haben hier die Tische eben auch bestückt.
So kann man die Küchenmaschine mal anfassen,
mal ausprobieren,
die Rührelemente in die Hand nehmen,
sich die Sets anschauen
und einfach schauen, was eben am besten zu einem passt.
Murat ist gerade megalaut, aber egal.
Der hat Spaß.
Der hat einfach Spaß hier.
Ja, also, was wir hier auch haben,
sind die Bosch Küchengeräte,
so wie bei mir zu Hause.
Ich meine, wir haben ja im Allgemeinen versucht,
das hier so nachzustellen, wie es bei uns zu Hause ist.
Das heißt, wenn man hier in der Küche steht,
sieht es ja wirklich aus wie bei mir daheim.
Deswegen trage ich natürlich auch immer meine Crocs.
Guck, Josh.
Ja, immer.
Ich komme hierher morgens
und dann habe ich immer gleich Hausschuhe an.
Das ist schon mal Pflicht.
Ihr könnt gern auch mit Hausschuhen kommen,
müsst aber nicht.
Also hier im Hintergrund haben wir die Holzwand,
die wir auch zu Hause haben,
und eben auch alle Geräte,
weil ich ganz oft unter den Videos in Kommentaren,
in Nachrichten gefragt werde:
Was kann denn der Bosch Backofen Serie 8?
Wie stelle ich die Dampffunktion ein?
Was kann ich denn alles
mit der Vakuumierschublade machen?
Und so weiter.
Da haben wir uns gedacht: "Wisst ihr was?
Wir packen alles auch hier mit in den Shop rein."
Wir verkaufen die Geräte hier nicht.
Die gibt es dann praktisch im Küchenfachhandel.
Und hier arbeiten wir einfach mit der Claudia zusammen,
Claudia Frey aus Kandel.
Die haben auch eine tolle Beratung.
Sie hat auch unsere Küche geplant
und wirklich alles wunderbar umgesetzt,
eben auch wie bei uns zu Hause.
Und da gibt es eben die Bosch Küchengeräte.
Und es steht dann auch immer schön dran.
Wir haben so kleine Schilder gemacht vorne dran.
Da steht dann dran, welcher Backofen eine Mikrowelle hat,
welcher eine Dampffunktion hat,
und eben so die spezifischen Einstellungen,
die man da so machen kann.
Und da kann man herkommen,
das mal kurz ausprobieren, sich durchklicken,
hier die Kühlschränke auch anschauen.
Also, wenn ihr hier auch vorbeikommt,
könnt ihr euch gern mal die Küche anschauen im Gesamten
und, ja, könnt mal schauen,
wie es ist so, in der Sally-Küche zu stehen.
Ja.
Ah, ich habe neulich mit der Ela telefoniert,
als ich hier war,
und habe Videotelefon gemacht
und habe mich in die Küche extra gestellt vor die Backöfen.
Und dann sagt die Ela:
"Mama, du bist doch zu Hause.
Aber ich war doch eben in der Küche.
Da warst du nicht. Wo bist du jetzt?"
Und da habe ich gesagt: "Ela, ich bin in der Küche."
Und sie: "Nein, Mama, aber...
Aber du bist doch in der Küche."
Und ich: "Nee, ich bin in Mannheim."
Und sie hat das gar nicht verstanden,
weil die Küche hier einfach genauso aussieht.
Das war ziemlich cool.
Ich wollte sie nicht veräppeln. Ich habe...
Ein bisschen. Ein bisschen vielleicht.
Ach, Ela!
[Musik]
Ja, das war es jetzt im Prinzip.
Also der Shop hat eröffnet.
Wir haben im Prinzip vor drei Tagen
still und heimlich geöffnet.
Mir tut es auch wirklich superleid!
Wir wollten ja die große Eröffnung machen
und Bescheid sagen.
Aber das Problem ist zum einen,
dass wir es nicht durften.
Das heißt, das Q 6 Q 7 darf momentan
maximal nur acht- bis neunhundert Menschen reinlassen.
Und wenn jetzt alle zu uns stürmen,
weil ich verkünde, dass wir offen haben,
sind die anderen Shops alle leer.
Das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Denn wir fühlen alle miteinander,
wir halten alle zusammen.
Und ich möchte natürlich auch, dass es
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: den anderen Stores hier drin gut geht.
>> MURAT: Denn hier gibt es auch richtig geniale,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: richtig tolle Stores.
>> SALLY: Ja. Also auch, wenn ihr zu uns kommt,
wenn ihr sagt: "Hey, ich komme jetzt nur wegen Sally hierher",
dann besucht bitte auch die anderen Stores.
Denn das sind wirklich
teilweise auch viele Familienunternehmen
und einfach schöne Betriebe, die es hier gibt.
Es gibt immer was tolles Neues zu entdecken.
Und es sind auch viele Shops, die es woanders gar nicht gibt.
>> MURAT: Genau. Unterstützt den Fachhandel!
Was ganz, ganz Wichtiges!
Habe ich davor schon auch schon immer gesagt gehabt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Unterstützt eure Innenstädte!
Was ganz, ganz Wichtiges!
Und normalerweise
– die Zeiten sind hart momentan.
Normalerweise bieten wir immer was zu kochen
– zu essen und zu trinken an kostenlos.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Dürfen wir momentan leider nicht machen.
Wir haben überall Maskenpflicht.
Ist alles in Ordnung.
Wir tun alles, dass es so schnell wie möglich vorbeigeht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und wir hoffen, dass es so schnell weg ist,
wie es gekommen ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und wir freuen uns auf euch in Mannheim.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, etwas kleines Positives hatte es.
Wir hatten jetzt praktisch die Zeit
so die letzten zwei, drei Wochen, uns einzuarbeiten.
Wir haben auch ein neues Team hier mit dabei.
Das heißt, wir haben noch mehr Arbeitsplätze geschaffen.
Und wir hatten jetzt einfach die letzten Tagen Zeit,
so ein bisschen langsam alles angehen zu lassen,
uns einzuarbeiten.
Aber natürlich fehlt mir einfach
so dieses Gefühl der großen Eröffnung
und ich hoffe
– und ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt
so ein verträumter Mädchengedanke ist,
aber ich hoffe, dass wir auf jeden Fall die Eröffnung als unsere
>> MURAT: nachholen.
>> SALLY: große Feier nachholen.
Dann koche ich für euch, ich backe für euch.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es gibt Getränke. Wir machen Kinderschminke.
Wir holen hoffentlich alles nach.
Und ich hoffe einfach jetzt auf euer Verständnis,
auch dass ihr draußen vielleicht warten müsst
in der Warteschlange
mit Abstand.
Und wir haben einfach Hygienevorschriften,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: die wir einhalten müssen.
>> MURAT: Ich habe einen Spruch! Ich habe einen Spruch!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ihr seid uns mit Abstand die liebsten Gäste.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So sieht es aus.
Ja.
Also vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen!
>> MURAT: Und ich gehe mal.
>> SALLY: Und das ist ein neues Kapitel in Sallys Welt.
>> MURAT: Und ich gehe mal ins Getümmel und gucke,
wem ich helfen kann
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: oder wo ich einfach mal
jemanden vollquatsche, okay?
Ich quatsche irgendwelche Leute voll.
>> SALLY: Au ja! Ich habe noch was zu sagen,
aber dafür kannst du kurz weg.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss. Ich quatsche die Leute voll.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Kann ich Ihnen helfen?
>> SALLY: Also ich werde den Murat öfter herschicken.
>> KUNDIN: Ich wollte mich nur mal umschauen.
>> SALLY: Denn, wenn ich mal in Waghäusel
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: meine Ruhe brauche beim Drehen
und beim Filmen,
dann sage ich einfach: "Murat, Mannheim braucht dich!"
Und dann schicke ich ihn einfach her.
Aber, wie gesagt, wir sind auch regelmäßig da
und ich freue mich auf euch.
Bis bald!
Tschüss!
Und willkommen im neuen Kapitel in Sallys Welt!
[Musik]